foreign
[Music]
just passed away
last year actually sorry didn't mean to
make it sound like she's like fighting
for her life thank God it was last year
just died
the thing is they they now know a link
to the cause of her death uh-oh and it
is something so tiny it is is the
husband an herbal remedy herbal so wait
Rhino horn it's a congresswoman that's
why congressman's wife yeah that's a
NorCal like Northern California yeah and
then so is there a significance to that
title like is she assassinated or some
[ __ ]
oh no no there's no like I mean they
they ruled her death accidental since
the beginning but they didn't they
weren't able to narrow down a cause and
it's something called a white mulberry
Leaf oh that's what moths eat right they
eat mulberry leaves oh I don't know fist
by the way oh silkworms
he does this but his biceps like up here
it's one of those dietary uh herbs that
you know like when people were doing fit
tea and all that [ __ ] and they were like
oh it makes me lose weight but they're
really just like all their Waters just
leaving diarrhea yeah and there's
constant Diaries just bad for you yeah
so like she had the effect that a lot of
people were warning others about during
that fit tea craze time and they were
saying like your uh intestines and
stomach can swell up that's what
happened to her and it was from like the
tiniest like they found like just a tiny
ass Mulberry loose in her stomach damn
yeah and she just like dropped dead yeah
she died from the inflammation did she
die looking pretty bomb though which are
you looking [ __ ] was she losing weight
did she achieve her goal or was it like
her first day on the diet that would
suck so bad she's like all right time to
change my life and then she [ __ ]
takes the supplement and dies it said
because she's not like she's not
overweight like this is how she looked
like prior to her bangable
but like like you wouldn't think a
person like that would need to go on a
diet like that right it said she had
diabetes yeah so it's also um she looks
fit right there yeah she looks good red
is a good color on her yeah it's
marketed that Mulberry Leaf is marketed
for diabetes and weight loss oh wait so
Mulberry Leaf she had an allergic
reaction or what was it no she had the
actual reaction that you get when you
when you're the danger that they tell
you for like cheese that dehydrate you
yeah when you're dehydrated from like a
supplement because it's like so rapid
and more than you should be dehydrated
your your uh organs can inflame and
that's how you die
so why are they selling this product
that's a good that's a good question so
the answer to that is that because it's
a known as an herbal or alternative
thing there's no control yeah that's how
they get you because there's no Food and
Drug for supplements it says there's
like 80 000 products on the shelves that
are considered like herbal or
alternative or a homeopathic or whatever
[ __ ] no yeah well that's exactly why
they don't regulate it because most of
them are considered [ __ ] and they
don't do anything they sell you a dream
but every now and then because of no
regulation something can slip through
the cracks that's just a little more
potent if under certain uh quantities my
mom used to get this um herbal
supplement for like it was it melaton it
wasn't uh melatonin but it was to sleep
so but it would [ __ ] make me like
kind of high and I loved it and I loved
it and I was like Mom I can't sleep
again I just cannot sleep and she goes
oh it's discontinued because there was
some kind of thing which I was like what
the [ __ ] are you talking I don't want to
hear that Mom what the [ __ ] mom the
illegal substance or something like that
so like you know how they do that [ __ ]
like four local right like oh yeah Dad
there was an illegal thing or some [ __ ]
they had to redo the formula well that's
that's what's kind of I wish I knew what
it was man because [ __ ] I was
hallucinating at night to go get the
generic Chinese herbal medicines work
though yeah I mean some arguably do good
things bad things it's all the thing is
it's not that they're saying uh they're
just saying they're really lacks on the
regulation because they assume it
doesn't need it but if certain things do
work then that means they can also work
against you because there's a potency
either direction and people react
differently too yeah it's just like when
there's 80 000 of those you know what I
mean like who's really gonna go oh I
found the one in the needle in the
haystack that actually does do something
and none of them do anything and a lot
of things independently go to shelves
like let's say you're a store and you're
gonna stock herbal stuff that's just
between you and the person making it you
don't have a third party that's going
let's see if this woman I died you know
like they're not doing that how come
they found this a year later
I think they have a lot to do so you
know it wasn't number one on the list
[ __ ] they were
at the drug
they were just going
to live what could have killed her it
takes a long time yeah to find like
autopsies and stuff and I guess you know
finally they were able to see that it
was this little plant was she feeling
like ill before was she feeling anything
or I should just like one day just died
and what was she wearing when she died
yeah that red pantsuit yeah so
supplements don't work dick watch not
those ones not the 50 ones the 50 ones
are basura they're all garbage what's
fit tea I see all the Instagram girls
promoting it so I don't know they have
diarrhea tea yeah yeah it's diarrhea tea
or it's like a bunch of caffeine it
makes you like you just like you lose
your water weight like oh so then people
think they're losing weight because they
they're just pissing out a lot yeah and
it also like has a way of kind of
quelling your appetite because you're
just [ __ ] sick you know you just
don't feel like eating it's like mad
caffeine you like fat burners or like a
combination of either like high caffeine
or appetite suppressant things like
there's like lollipops that you could
eat that are like Diet suppressant
appetite suppressant I mean those sounds
dangerous my friend used to do
Hydroxycut and I'm like oh that's wasn't
that right god dude and I [ __ ] them up
because he was fat I was really skinny
during that time so we both had the
opposite thing we're trying to do and he
was on this Hydroxycut [ __ ] and I was
like that [ __ ] don't seem right I feel
like there was a class action lawsuit
against it for sure yeah it was uh back
in that day
um so like something that's really
effective actually for losing weight is
ephedra but the problem is it makes your
heart beat like a [ __ ] so the
side effect is insane that's right and
then uh but before they regulated it
like all the fat burners of the day had
it in it but then I think people started
dying because of heart complications
they have to take it out but like
Hydroxycut xenodrine like a bunch of
people had ephedra in it and that's
that's the whole thing about like
substances that are off the shelf is
that if you look at the bottle of
anything right it'll say
um if it's a controlled substance it'll
say consult your physician right because
every single thing that's available
could affect someone differently
depending on their own like you know
their body or whatever other medication
they're taking like yeah because if
you're like let's say you're a drinker
or whatever and the night before you
could have drank alcohol and maybe it's
not out of your system so you take
something that has like ephedra in it in
the morning it it's going to hit you
three times harder than what it's
supposed to hit you know yeah that's
what they suspect happened with her is
that it might have been in combination
with some prescription medicine yeah
yeah yeah yeah because of that you know
and not Consulting with what'll do what
and when she experienced what happened
with like the low blood sugar and yeah
and then passed away and there hasn't
been another reported death from white
mulberry plants so it's kind of like a
freak accident because of like the
combination of whatever her unique
lifestyle was in that moment yeah it
could be and that might have just been
you know the element that caused the
whole equation to go Haywire what about
vitamins
do they work well isn't isn't vitamins
like they it's pointless to take too
much of it yeah right like your body
can't even process thousand percent
vitamin C oh like yeah when you take
like emergency or Airborne it's like
this is like 1500 vitamin C but your
body can only handle 100 I take
emergency for the electrolytes sometimes
if I don't have like an electrolyte
drink I'll just like pour it in there
but it really depends like you could
probably get most of your food from just
most vitamins from like food from food
from an orange but then if you're
missing it then you that's why people
take like a multivitamin so it's like it
covers their bases or they take like an
athletic greens because it has all that
stuff but then for you to like go
through each vitamin be like am I
absorbing enough of these vitamins else
I'm eating them it's like it's you might
as well just not even work are there
vitamins that are just not that
important you don't really need them all
no they're all important all the most
they're both dependent though the most
important vitamins your body will make
it like your body itself will make it
you know but then the problem is it's
like so I think we're in a very like
shortcut Society ID so these things are
called supplements right it's supposed
to supplement what you're supposed to do
so if you're having a good diet you
drink water you sleep then you probably
don't even need it yeah but it's or like
the the the the law of diminishing
returns is so little it's like yeah
maybe you can optimize your body by 10
whatever but people I think are just
skipping all of that and then they go
you know what I don't even eat
vegetables at all so I'm gonna eat
athletic greens yeah but it's like you
should probably do it the other way
around or get like all your Greens in
first and then the occasional timer
traveling whatever like oh here this
will help me fill the Gap it's the other
way around supplements are like plus or
minus five percent change yeah a lot of
times so because not only because of
this but the FDA is trying to get
um supplement makers to list the
ingredients of everything they have but
there's a council of um responsible
nutrition who protects supplement makers
and they're lobbying against that saying
that that's like giving your recipe a
counsel for more responsible nutrition
because you know what they do that's
weird a lot of these companies that are
like kind of sketch they'll cover up
their Blends and like proprietary yeah
yeah yeah so it's like they can't really
tell you what's in there or they'll name
it like a lot of Fitness uh ones are
like Alpha size that's our proprietary
blend or whatever yeah and then they you
know those are the shitty ones yeah they
don't tell you exactly what's in there
but like unless you go to barbell
Brigade they'll actually no for real
though like like everything's missed it
out everything's listed out in the
dosage and that's why it's important but
then like a lot of companies don't have
that transparency yeah that's why here
with 10 on Code
10 on yeah dude where's these where's
the ingredients right ten percent plus
whey protein is this can you cook with
these instructions no it looks like
you're hiding something Buddy
so the milligrams are here though
it's right here
but if you also want to lose weight get
the get lean program for 15 on right now
use my promo code for an additional 15
on your when you check out
Joe schmoe Joe schmoe
[Music]
[Music]
foreign